FREDERICK: So hello, everybody.
My name is Fredrick.
And I have the
pleasure to welcome you
to an inspiring hour full
of imagination, creativity,
and innovation.
Where we can learn how to
get ideas out of our heads
and into the world.
Please join me in welcoming
bestselling author
and professor at Stanford, my
great friend Dr. Tina Sellig.
[APPLAUSE]
Tina, great to have
you back at Google.
TINA SEELIG: It's so fun.
Thank you very much,
I've done this.
This is my third time, and
I'm delighted to be back.
FREDERICK: So you're a best
selling author and professor
of practice at Stanford
University where
you teach a course.
It's called MSE 277, on
innovation creativity.
You are also the
executive director
of the STVP, Stanford's
Technology of Interest Program.
And your books include "What
I Wish I Knew When I Was 20",
and "inGenius: A Crash
Course on Creativity."
Your latest book, which
I have here my hands,
is called "Inside Out".
So Tina, tell me, before I dive
into the book, what motivated
you to write this book?
And where do you draw
your inspiration from?
TINA SEELIG: Great.
You know, I think in books.
It's funny, I started writing
my first book many years ago.
My first two books were actually
on the chemistry of cooking.
I realized what was
happening in my lab.
I knew that in great depth,
but not in my kitchen.
And I made a list of
all the questions I had,
and I couldn't find the answers.
It was way back in 1991
when that book came out.
And so I figured I better write
a book to find the answers.
So I am very curious.
And I, in teaching classes
on creativity and innovation
for the last 15 years,
realized there was a big hole.
There was a big missing piece.
And I know you teach
a very similar class,
so I'm hoping that
my contributions also
help you as well.
I realize that we use the terms
imagination and creativity
interchangeably.
We often use the terms
creativity and innovation
interchangeably.
And a lot of people use
the terms innovation
and entrepreneurship
interchangeably.
And what happens is
this sloppiness results
in a lot of problems.
One of the biggest
problems is that people
think you can't teach this.
They don't know
what it exactly is.
And they assume
it's just innate.
And therefore, they
don't put any effort
into thinking that they
could actually get better.
And so I realized
I really wanted
to put a stake in the ground in
terms of what these things are
and actually how one could
move through the process
of generating the idea and
then bringing it to life.
FREDERICK: And as you mentioned,
we teach both a course
on innovation and creativity.
So I think we share the
belief that everybody
is a creative person and
a creative individual.
And you help really
explore people,
their identity as an
innovator and find confidence
and creativity as well.
So what are some practical tips
you can give us to really bring
the best out of ourselves?
TINA SEELIG: Great.
So there are so many
things that you can
do to increase your creativity.
And I do agree.
I think we're all creative.
But in the same
way that we all can
learn about math or
history or music or sports.
We have very different
starting points.
There's some people who are
naturally very creative.
Others really need
much more coaching.
But there are definitely tools.
There's a combination of
knowledge, skills, and mindset.
And this is very important.
It's not just what
you do, it's also
the way you approach problems.
So what I do in my class,
and I know you do as well,
is focus a lot on
helping students
push through the first
wave of solutions
to come up with
real innovations.
And this is one of the
key goals is teaching them
how to look at the problems
they ask in the first place.
Sort of reframing the problem.
We so often go with
the first framing
of a problem we come up with.
And that often might
not be the best way
to think of the solutions.
I'll give you just
a simple example.
Does anyone in this
room have a birthday
this week, or coming up?
Actually, today's my
father's birthday,
so we'll do it
with my father, OK?
He's 89 today.
We could go out of our way
to brainstorm about the best
birthday party for my dad.
And that might be a great idea.
But if we change one word
in that prompt to let's
plan the best birthday
celebration-- what happened
to the set of solutions?
It expanded dramatically.
OK, what if we said we wanted
to come up with the best way
to mark my father's birthday?
That would expand even larger.
And the profound piece
of this-- and I really
think it's quite profound--
Is it the answer was actually
baked into the question.
If you said let's
plan a birthday party,
the assumption was
that it was a party.
If you said let's
plan a celebration,
the assumption is that
it's a celebration.
And so if you don't question
the questions you ask,
you really are missing
a huge opportunity.
So that's one way that
you help people unpack
their own creativity
is just even thinking
about the questions
they're asking.
FREDERICK: I think you quote
at some stage Larry Page
about moonshots and
setting ambitious goals.
So tell us a little bit
more about this concept
and what inspires
you around that?
TINA SEELIG: Yeah,
you know, it's
fascinating because
everybody figures out
what stage they want
to play out their life.
They figure out the
impact they want to have.
An example, a simple
example would be you
could design a brand new
cookie in your kitchen.
You can add some
interesting ingredients
and come up with something
that no one has done before.
And you could just share it with
your friends and your family.
Or you could say, hey, I'm going
to sell it at the local farmers
market.
Or I'm going to open
up a cookie store.
Or I'm going to start a
national cookie chain.
Or I'm going to open up an
entire global baking business.
That all starts with one cookie.
And so if you have
the idea that you
want to do something
big and bold,
you're going to give yourself
permission to come up
with these big, bold ideas.
You know, it takes-- we all
have the same 24 hours in a day,
right?
And so it takes
just as much time
to do something big and bold as
it does to do something small.
So giving yourself permission
to think in really big,
broad, bold strokes
is really powerful.
And of course Google is such
an amazing example of that.
I use lots of examples
from Google all the time,
and I think we should all look
to Google as an inspiration
because not only the
impact the company's had
on our everyday lives, but
the culture of experimentation
and really taking on
very big challenges.
FREDERICK: So I think setting
yourselves ambitious goals is
one thing, or having ideas.
But how can we actually get
those ideas out of our head
and into the real world?
Because I think that's
also your tagline here.
So can you give us a
recipe how we can actually
make those ideas a reality.
TINA SEELIG: Yeah,
it's interesting,
I was mentioning
before we started
that I did a Reddit
AMA last week, which
was totally amazing.
And the thing that came up
after the thousands of people
who signed into the conversation
was their frustration
with the same problem.
They said I have all
these great ideas,
but I don't know
what to do next.
I'm afraid that someone
is going to steal my idea.
Or I'm afraid that if I
do it, it's going to fail.
And it's such an
interesting thing
to see that people
actually haven't
been taught that process.
So here's the model that I've
presented in the book, which
I call the invention cycle.
And the idea-- you'll see
at theend why it's a cycle--
the idea is that you
start with imagination.
Imagination takes two things.
It requires one
mindset, and one action.
The mindset is engaging.
Engaging with the
world, and then
actively envisioning
what could be different.
This is something a
lot of people don't do,
but the idea is that
every single day,
you're going down the street.
You're going to see
opportunities of problems that
need to get solved, and
then you can envision
what you'd do differently.
In fact, before something is
your passion and something
that you dive into,
it's likely something
that you know nothing about.
And there's so many
examples of that.
I'm sure that all
the people who are
in this room or the
people who are watching
are doing things in their
lives that at some point,
they didn't know anything about.
But once they got
engaged with it,
the opportunities start
opening up for them.
So that's the imagination stage.
But now that you've envisioned
what might be different,
you move on to the
creativity stage.
And that requires motivation
and experimentation.
Now the wonderful
thing is, you can
start with a little
bit of motivation.
You don't need a lot.
A little bit of motivation
leads to small experiments.
I know you spend a lot
of time teaching people
how to prototype.
And that is such an
incredible skill, to say,
I don't have to do everything.
In fact, I can just with
a little bit of curiosity
and motivation, do
some quick prototypes
to see what might happen.
And of course, the
results of that--
whether they work or they
don't-- will then fuel
your motivation.
And so you end up getting this
wonderful cycle of motivation
and experimentation
that leads you
ultimately to the next
step, which is innovation.
So creative ideas are new to
you, but not new to the world.
But when you then get
to the innovation stage,
that's when you push through.
That's with great focus, so
the mental state of focusing,
leads to then reframing.
And we talked about
that a minute ago,
the sort of the birthday party,
the birthday celebration.
By reframing, that's
when you come up
with real innovations that
are not just new to you.
They're also new to the world.
And once you've mastered that--
and each one of these steps
gets harder than
the one before--
but once you've
mastered that, you then
go to the
entrepreneurship stage,
which requires great persistence
and inspiring others.
You can not do
these things alone.
I mean, look at
this amazing company
with all of these people.
The things that
are happening here
would only happen
because other people have
been inspired to join the team.
And that is the cycle aspect, is
you get to the entrepreneurship
stage, where you inspire others
imagination, which then started
their cycle all over again.
FREDERICK: Great.
Let me come back to the
entrepreneurship in a second.
I want to stay a little bit
longer on the experimentation
and prototyping.
Again, I find it
truly inspiring how
you talk about this as well.
And you mention in
your book something
where we can learn a lot
from children actually
and how they experiment
and try out new things.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that?
TINA SEELIG: Yeah.
isn't it true?
I often ask people in
audiences were you creative
when you were a kid and ask, do
you have kids who are creative?
You've got kids,
are they creative?
FREDERICK: Absolutely,
I think so.
Like every other kid.
TINA SEELIG: Like every
other kid, exactly.
And then what happens?
And you'd ask adults
are you creative?
And a huge number say no.
And we say what happened?
There are very
few other things I
can think of besides learning
new languages that we
get worse as we get older.
I mean, isn't that
totally crazy that people
get worse at being
creative as they get older.
And it certainly comes down
to our school systems--
people are very
responsive to the rules,
the rewards, the incentives
that are put in place.
And our schools are set
up in so many places--
I mean not everywhere,
but in so many
places-- where there's
one right answer,
and you are not encouraged
to come up with really
creative solutions to problems.
So the thing that
we have to do is
sort of unlearn that and to
give people the permission
to think the same way that
they did when they were kids.
FREDERICK: So we
both sailed on a ship
called "The Entrepreneurship"
in March 2013.
Just a fascinating experience.
So we passed glaciers
in Patagonia in Chile,
and experienced wild waters.
I think we both got
seasick at some time.
And we also went to Cape
Horn with about 90 students
from Chile and Stanford who
wanted to become entrepreneurs.
So what did you take
away from this experience
around entrepreneurship?
And how do you describe
that in your book?
TINA SEELIG: And so this is
sort of an interesting story.
I was down in Chile.
I do a lot of work in Chile
with university down there.
And we're partners.
And I was trying to get
them to think really
big, the sort of the moon shot.
They were coming
up with all sorts
of ideas for their programs
that were very incremental.
And I said you
need to think big.
You need to think.
what if we had a ship.
What if we had an
entrepreneurship?
And of course once you
come up with the idea
for an entrepreneurship,
you have to do it, right?
So as I write about
in the book, this
was a true entrepreneurial
endeavor to make this happen.
Once we came up
with the idea, it
was a very bold,
new innovative idea.
But getting other people
involved was quite a challenge.
It was expensive.
It was politically challenging.
We had to recruit
all sorts of people.
And it took us two years to
make that idea come to life.
But it was such a
wonderful experience.
So we took, as you said,
about 90 students and probably
around 20 faculty members from
several different institutions
down there.
And over the course of
this time together, they
were given local challenges.
So we had people who brought
in problems from the region.
You know, how do you
increase ecotourism?
How to help the school system
that was down in Chile?
Taking one of the ports
there and figuring out
how to increase their
economic prosperity.
And what was super
fabulous about it
was that these
students came together
from different cultures and
found really remarkable ways
to work together.
I think they didn't
quite know how
that was going to
work-- from very
different cultures,
different languages,
different backgrounds.
But by bringing them together
with very, very different
points of view, they
were able to come up
with some very exciting ideas.
FREDERICK: Fantastic.
So what's the one thing based
on what you write in your book
here, "Inside Out" or your
other books, what you would just
give to Googlers about moving
forward and finding confidence
in their creativity again?
TINA SEELIG: Yeah,
a tremendous amount
is sort of an inside game.
It's about giving
yourself permission.
Permission to
challenge assumptions,
to break the rules,
to make your own luck.
One of the things I
talk about in this book
is that when you
get a job, any job,
you are not just
getting that job.
You are getting the
keys to the building.
Add that that's true in so
many places where you go.
You go inside and
the opportunities
start making themselves
sort of visible,
and then it's up to you to
really make things happen.
And I'm sure that this
is an organization that
supports that.
I know at Stanford
that's true is
there's so many opportunities.
I was fortunate.
I came in a very different
role than I'm in now.
And over the 16 years
that I've been there,
have ended up founding
lots of different programs
and organizations.
None of these things were in
my original job description,
but they were opportunities
that presented themselves.
So I would say, really
seize opportunities
that are in front of you.
You can make amazing things
happen that other people can't
do because they don't
have the same insights you
have based on your experiences.
FREDERICK: Fantastic.
So I'd love to see how
you scale your insights as
well, like offering an offline
course for only 40 students.
Then taking that
online to inspire like,
I think the last course
with about 30,000 students
participating.
And now with the book even
going to the millions,
so congratulations on that.
So what's next for Tina?
TINA SEELIG: Well,
you know what,
I'm always looking for ways
that I can have an impact.
And a lot of it is drawn, as
I said, from my own curiosity.
One of the reasons
I write books is not
to sell a million copies.
It's that writing
a book is a way
to really focus your
thoughts and your attention.
Teaching is great.
You have to spend a lot of
time thinking things through.
But you can still
do a lot of hand
waving when you're teaching.
When you actually
write a book, you
need to be extraordinarily
careful about your ideas.
You read them over
again and again.
And oftentimes when
I'm writing a book,
I question a lot of the
things that I actually believe
and come up with some very,
very different points of view.
So I can even give
you examples of that,
where I start out
thinking one thing
and once I finished the
book, I go wow, actually,
that's not right at all.
Or that was a superficial
interpretation.
It's actually much
more nuanced than that.
So I write books.
I write to think.
And it's been a really
wonderful process for me.
FREDERICK: Excellent.
So I want to also encourage
you to give yourself permission
to ask some questions.
AUDIENCE: So I
wanted to see if you
had any tips for how we can
continue to foster this really
entrepreneurship
culture or really
creative culture
in a big company.
TINA SEELIG: Yeah,
well you're very
fortunate to be in a company
that I believe really
encourages this.
But I know that in a lot of big
companies, that's not the case.
And in fact, this is
something that happens a lot.
You can chime in if you
have heard this as well.
The students come
out of our classes,
and they're so
really enthusiastic
about their new found creative
confidence and skills.
And then they realize they're
going to go into a company
where that may or
may not be supported.
So there are few
things you can do.
One is to find
like minded people.
They're always other
people in the organization
who are equally enthusiastic.
Find them, find your
tribe in the organization.
Also, do some experiments.
Do some prototypes.
One of my colleagues said,
so brilliantly in our class,
and I quoted in the
book, it's Rich Cox.
He said, asking for
permission just transfers
the risk to someone else.
And this is super
important to keep in mind.
If you ask your boss
or your colleague
or someone else on your team
for permission to do something,
then they can easily say no.
And then you've been shut down.
But if you do a
little experiment
and actually can show
some data that it works,
you're much more
likely to get a yes.
So do some little experiments
to try out your ideas,
and then go back to people
with actually some real data.
AUDIENCE: I was curious,
you just mentioned briefly
the decline of creativity
as we get older.
And that's in part
due to school systems.
And I was wondering
as well, it seems
like in at least
Silicon Valley, there's
an increasing focus on
getting productivity out
of every moment of time.
And I read a little
bit of research
about the importance
of play for children
in fostering a
creative sense, And I
was curious if you
see a conflict develop
at all in the direction
that things are moving
in terms of more and more
productivity and screen time
for kids.
And if so, if any of your
work focuses on that?
TINA SEELIG: Yet, it's
such an interesting thing.
I was saying as I walk in here,
every time I come to Google,
it looks like a
summer camp, right?
I'm walking by, there's
the organic garden.
There's the volleyball court.
And the question is, how does
this affect your productivity?
And in our discussion
earlier, my understanding
is in a place like this,
there is an attempt
to get that balance
so that you end up
having both the focus on your
very specific project you're
working on, but there's
time to let loose and relax.
And so I think giving
yourself permission
to do that is super important.
And also thinking about
the types of spaces
that you need to do
different types of work.
It's something I'm
very interested in
is how space affects
your creativity
and your productivity.
I find that each of
the books I've written,
I write in different places.
Different spaces stimulate
different type of thinking,
and I find that I need very
different types of spaces
to think in different ways.
For example, when I wrote "What
I Wish I Knew When I Was 20",
it was very much a
very personal book.
It was like an open letter to my
son who's going off to college.
And I wrote in a room that
was all the curtains down.
It was very quiet.
And it was something that felt
very-- it was very insulated.
When I got my book
"Ingenious", I
wrote with wide open
windows and high ceilings,
and I needed a very
expansive environment
to really stretch my thinking.
So I'm a huge fan of
thinking about the space
that you need to
actually extract
the most from your work.
And they're going to
be places where you're
going to be more productive,
and places where you're
going to be more creative.
AUDIENCE: So where did
you write this one?
TINA SEELIG: So this book--
you know, it's funny.
Don't tell anyone.
I wrote this book in bed.
But I have a very nice bedroom
with windows and high ceilings.
And I wrote this
book every morning,
I would sit and write
for a couple of hours.
Sitting in bed,
watching the sun rise.
AUDIENCE: I guess I had
another question as well.
You mentioned that your
thoughts on creativity
when you're writing the book
had changed in certain regards.
And also, the course has been
out I guess over 10 years
now too, right?
So how has that evolved?
TINA SEELIG: Yeah.
The course I teach changes
really, at least 30%
every year.
I get bored very, very easily.
And so I want to be as delighted
and surprised by the projects
as the students are.
And so I also never like to
give the same project twice
because I don't
want to be anchored
by the results of the project
the students did before.
So let me tell you that what
we did this last quarter, which
was mind-bendingly amazing.
In fact, it's so amazing that
I'm tempted to do it again.
So I think maybe there's
a way I can do it
by reframing the question.
We worked with San Quentin
prison, state prison,
which is up in Marin.
And the project
was on redesigning
the reentry process of going
from prison to freedom.
And the students were incredibly
moved by this challenge,
and the projects
were incredible.
So what happened is we
brought in a bunch of folks
to the class the
students could interview
and also made many other
people available for them
to interview who were former
prisoners, parole officers,
folks who play different
roles in the prison system.
And also the students got
to go up to San Quentin
and they taught
classes up there.
So it's a program I work with
called The Last Mile that
is an amazing program that
teaches entrepreneurship
at San Quentin.
And I've been teaching
in the program myself,
and found it incredibly moving.
It was incredible to
teach these men who
are hungry for the type
of lessons that we teach.
They have had no
exposure to this,
although they're very bright
and very entrepreneurial.
So how do you get
them to channel
their natural
entrepreneurial spirit
into doing things that are
going to be really socially
responsible?
So the students got to teach
classes up there and came back,
and their job was to redesign
that reentry process.
And the insights
they can came up with
were really very,
very interesting.
And in fact, two of the- there
were eight teams-- and two
of the projects are
already being implemented
that they came up with.
AUDIENCE: Very nice.
Visitors to Google
Companies come
to Google almost daily,
or at least weekly.
And they're always
looking for ways
to make their company
more innovative.
And so there's rules, there's
guidelines in the book.
But then they also ask
for quantitative backing
to back it up.
So is creativity
something that needs
to be in a report and
spreadsheet format?
How would you do that?
Is it really the goal
that you should be asking,
or these companies
should be asking.
TINA SEELIG: It's such
an interesting thing.
One of the challenges
about teaching creativity
is that it's really
hard to measure,
just like it's hard to measure
things like ethics or love.
And there's a wonderful
quote from Einstein
that I'm probably
going to butcher here,
but it's something that
says "all things that count,
can't be counted.
And all things that
count, can be counted,
don't necessarily count."
And I think that this
is super important
when we think about creativity.
It is something
that matters a lot,
but it's really hard to measure.
And especially when you
think about the fact
that we're planting
seeds that often
take a very long time
to actually sprout
and to form large trees.
I mean, if you think
about-- listen Cliff,
you're 10 years out of school.
Think of the things
that have happened
in '10 years, or the
lessons you use today
that you might have
learned 10 years ago.
And we see this.
I run a lot of
programs at Stanford.
One of them is the
Mayfield Fellows program,
which is a dozen students
who are with us for nine
months in intensive program.
Most of those students have
very entrepreneurial tendencies
and interests.
But most of them don't
end up starting companies
until four, five,
six, seven years
after they get out of school.
They go and work
at other companies.
They might come to Google.
They might go to Microsoft.
They might go to Amazon.
And then they learn about
the opportunities, really
big opportunities,
once they're immersed.
They realize that when
they're in school,
they don't actually know the
problems that they really
want to tackle and solve.
And so once they get
out into industry,
that's when they start
seeing not only how
these businesses work, but
they really become passionate
about something they really
want to dive into themselves.
In fact, interestingly
enough, the Instagram guys
were in our program,
and that's how they met.
But they went off
to other companies
and then came together several
years later to start that firm.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about generating ideas.
And I don't want to
create a false dichotomy,
but I'm going to ask the
question anyway if that's OK.
So my question is, do you think
that creative and new ideas are
thought of deliberately and
consciously through a process
like brainstorming.
Or are they formed
more organically,
almost as if they're
stumbled upon
by doing experiments
out in the field,
or by perhaps
subconscious processes?
TINA SEELIG: Can
the answer be both?
Right.
So the fact is, it is a
very complicated process
to generate new ideas.
And so what we do is
we give a lot of tools
to help you get there.
Clearly, it's something
that happens in your brain.
I'm actually a
neuroscientist by training.
I did my PhD In neuroscience
at Stanford Med School
a few years ago.
And people when
they ask me how does
creativity work in the brain,
I can answer confidently
that we do not know.
But we certainly
know that our brain
is responsible for
helping us generate ideas.
And so, we need to
do things that help
us stretch our imagination.
One is by getting lots
of different experiences.
The more experiences you have,
the more you have to work with.
Think about it.
If you're in your
kitchen, and you're
trying to come up
with a new recipe,
the more ingredients you
have, the more options
you're going to have
to reconnect them.
So one, you need experiences.
But then you need some
tools to help you figure out
the tools you can use to
connect and combine them,
to reframe them, to saute
them, to broil them,
to whisk them up.
And so that's what
we do in our classes
is we give people an opportunity
to learn the different tools
just like you would in
a kitchen, the tools
that you can use once you
have these ingredients.
But the goal is also to get as
many ingredients as you can.
So it's something you can do.
Talk to someone who's
outside of your field.
Read books that are
something you never pick up.
Go travel somewhere you
haven't been before.
Watch a movie that
stretches your mind.
These things give you
more to work with.
And so yes, it--
but you know what,
we are natural problem solvers.
We would not be sitting
in this building,
we would not be up doing the
type of scientific research
that we do if we weren't
naturally creative and curious.
And so what we're
really doing is
we're tapping into
our natural skills
and helping to polish
them to make us better.
Does that make sense?
So I'm curious, who
here feels like they
get to be creative in
everything they do every day?
I mean, is something that
you think of every day
as using creativity?
Yes?
Yeah?
It's something
that's interesting.
I think that one
of the problems is
is that people
often don't define
what they're doing as being
creative when they really are.
Because if you said, are
you a problem solver?
You would answer yes.
But are you creative?
You might not say yes.
So I think being able to
just sort of understand
that when you're solving
problems, every single day,
from the mundane to
the big and grand,
this is an opportunity
every single day
to be stretching your
imagination to learning
how to be more creative.
AUDIENCE: So you also mentioned
in the education sphere,
at least in American education,
it's traditionally not
very creative.
It encourages a set
path of thinking.
At the same time, there's
tens of thousands of schools
nationwide, hundreds of
thousands of more teachers.
How can you start to change
that conversation at such
a wide scale for the kids?
TINA SEELIG: Great.
And I think this is
incredibly important.
It doesn't mean
that we don't want
to teach a lot of things
we already teach in school.
But in parallel, we need to
give students an opportunity
to have open ended problems that
don't have one right answer.
Also, we need to
give them an option
to follow their own interests.
This is something that I find
so sad is when kids come out
of school, and they've
never had an opportunity
to do creative writing, or
to do their own artwork,
or to take a topic-- might
even be baseball-- and just
follow it as far as their
interest takes them.
This is what propels us
forward later in life.
And we need to give
people the skills
to do that starting earlier.
This is why I'm hoping that
the framework that I've
crafted and presented
in this book
creates a model that can
be used by educators.
I mean, that's really
one of my hopes
is that if you actually
have some definitions--
and let me just sort of
remind us what these are.
That imagination is envisioning
things that don't yet exist.
Creativity is applying your
imagination to solve a problem
or to address a challenge.
Innovation is applying
your creativity
to come up with a
unique solution.
And entrepreneurship is
applying your innovation
to bring it to the world.
So what this is is a
hierarchy of skills
going from imagination
to creativity,
innovation to entrepreneurship.
As a result, you can then learn
the attitudes and actions that
have to happen along the way.
And so just as you learned
how to read and write--
we start out as babies
where we're babbling.
We learn how to
apply those sounds
to make words, the
words to make sentences,
and the sentences
to make stories.
You can go through
the same process
in learning to be more
creative and entrepreneurial
by going from really learning
how to hone your imagination.
How to then apply
that to be creative.
Apply that to become
really innovative.
And apply that to
become entrepreneurial.
And I think that with having
that type of framework,
we can really
encourage educators
to think about how they
bake this into their classes
and give students an opportunity
to really master these skills.
FREDERICK: So Tina,
thank you once more
for inspiring all of us
and taking the time out
of your busy schedule
to come over to Google.
Highly recommend "Inside Out".
It's actually available
in the back for $10.
And Tina kindly agreed to
stay a little bit longer
to sign your personal copies.
So thank you very much.
TINA SEELIG: Great,
thank you very much.
My pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]